nous allons commencer la piste vous
allez vous mettre en tenue ont peu moins
bon
q représenter d'exercice exactement cet
exercice qui ne piste du risque qui sert
à l'entraînement des soldats du 23e rima
et du rmt qui utilisent le fort de
corneille des installations sur lequel
existe 22 obstacles ici les gens vous
avez la descente en v qui vient d'être
exécuté par grâce au delà et que la
difficulté que nous rencontrons dans cet
exercice c'est surtout une question
d'appréhension au point de vue vide
et puis au point de vue équilibre bon
alors ici le deuxième exercice deuxième
exercice c'est une roulette qui a une
trentaine de mètres de long et l'arrivée
se termine par un roulé boulé
on doit arriver à environ 25 km
l'obstacle sigean et double vous avez
d'abord un pont ouistiti composé de deux
cordes plus exactement à calais une
corde au dessus sur lequel on doit
marcher se laisser glisser et ensuite
vous avez une tyrolienne horizontale que
l'on prend en se couchant dessus et on
avance a fait la force des bras et en
cédant également avec un pied qui est
posé sur la corde l'autre pied reste
libre et sert de balancier pour l'
équilibre
il ya quand même énormément de risques
je suppose que vous assurez vos hommes
il ya pas mal de risques seules les
moniteurs passe sans être assurés parce
que ça se trouve quand même à une
vingtaine de mètres au dessus du sol et
vous risquez de deux délits c'est assez
facilement si ce sont des pas de géant
et de plots qu'il s'agit de traverser le
plus rapidement possible alors ici le
rappelle ici une descente en rappel qui
vous emmène dans une fosse du fort et on
remonte de cette fausse par une escalade
le long d'une paroi qui est d'ailleurs
assez compliqué car elle est tout
verticale
voilà
ici vous avez une à stage fait qu'une
tout sur laquelle il s'agit de se lancer
une plate forme et pour remonter de la
fosse vous avez une échelle spéléo ici
vous avez un espalier ou plutôt ce sont
des barres de spa qu'il s'agit de
prendre dans la foulée on monte on doit
redescendre et sauter à toute vitesse
c'est une question d'appréhension quand
on arrive en haut beaucoup s'arrêtent
les refusent quel est le record sur
votre parcours
14 minutes et quelques secondes sur
parcours qui fait plus d'un kilomètre de
long et compte 22 obstacles et quel est
le but exact quand même de ces exercices
de ces exercices doivent donner enfin
beaucoup de plus de réflexes de soldats
et puis de s'aguerrir également au point
de vue physique sous le plan sportif
satisfait at on pas trop pourquoi pas
soit il ya des au stade d ici que tu
refuses questions fusent souvent il ya
des enfants des jeunes qui ne l'on va
super sur les pistes mais la plupart au
bout de quelques essais arrive à être à
passer souvent et il n'y a pas de refus
systématique enfin des obstacles au
début quand même souvent ils ont
beaucoup d'appréhension en particulier
pour les premiers obstacles j'ai pu voir
la tyrolienne le la roulette la descente
en veille et ici le dernier obstacle où
il y en a souvent il y aura eu une image
du dernier qui n'est pas le seul et qui
représente la majorité